En este video quiero demostrarte que el producto
o la multiplicación de un racional...
de un racional...
esto por un irracional...
por un irracional...
irracional...
esto nos da un número irracional...
irracional.
Y ojo, estoy diciendo que estoy tomándome
esta multiplicación del racional por este irracional
y nos da un irracional, si este
racional es distinto de 0,
porque si fuera 0, 0 por lo que sea es 0
y me daría un número racional.
Ok y para llegar a esto, que parece ser que
tiene todo el sentido lógico del mundo,
voy a ocupar una demostración por contradicción,
es decir, voy a suponer que no llegamos a
un número irracional y vamos a llegar
a una contradicción
y si no llegamos a un número irracional,
entonces eso quiere decir que
vamos a llegar a un número racional.
Así que bueno, para tener la demostración
por contradicción,
lo que voy a hacer es primero suponer...
vamos a ponerlo aquí....
voy a suponer...
a suponer lo contrario...
suponer...
suponer que la multiplicación de un racional...
racional...
racional por un irracional...
por un irracional...
irracional...
como queremos llegar a una contradicción,
entonces voy a suponer lo contrario,
voy a suponer que nos lleva a un número racional...
nos lleva a un número racional...
ahora, si veo que esto no tiene sentido,
si llego a una contradicción,
entonces no me quedaría de otra, la multiplicación de un racional por un irracional, me daría un irracional...
Bueno, para esto que te parece si este racional,
el del principio, le ponemos un nombre,
a este de aquí lo voy a ver como
"a" entre "b", ok.
"a" entre "b" lo voy a multiplicar por un
número irracional y como un número irracional
es muy, pero muy, pero muy largo lo voy a
denotar con "x", mi número irracional,
este número irracional le voy a llamar "x", ok...
y esto nos tiene que dar un número racional,
eso quiere decir que esto es lo mismo,
lo mismo que un número racional,
que le voy a poner el nombre de "m" entre "m"...
de "m" entre "m", ok.
Y estamos suponiendo que esto es cierto,
pero bueno, si esto es cierto, entonces podemos
despejar a "x" y para despejar a "x",
que te parece si multiplico todo,
tanto el lado izquierdo como el lado derecho de esta igualad por "b" entre "a"...
por "b" entre "a"
y este lado también por "b" entre "a"...
por "b" entre "a"...
de tal manera que éste se va a cancelar con éste...
éste se va a cancelar con éste...
y del lado izquierdo solamente me queda mi "x",
mi número irracional.
"x" va a ser igual...
y del lado derecho me queda "m" entre "n"
por "b" entre "a", ahora date cuenta que "m"
entre "n" por "b" entre "a"
es exactamente lo mismo por propiedades de multiplicación de dos números racionales
que "m" por "b"... que "m" por "b"
esto dividido entre "n" por "a"...
entre "n" por "a"...
déjame cambiar de color...
por "a"...
Ok, ahora, date cuenta de lo siguiente,
aquí pasa algo muy, pero muy feo,
yo tengo "m" por "b",
lo cual es un número entero entre "n" por "a",
es un número entero porque estoy
multiplicando dos números racionales
y date cuenta que "m" por "b" entre "n" por "a"
es un número racional, éste de aquí...
éste de aquí,
déjame ponerlo con este color...
éste de aquí es un número racional
porque tengo...
racional...
porque tengo la proporción
de dos números enteros,
pero "x" habíamos dicho que era
un número completamente irracional,
de hecho es justo como nos tomamos a "x",
como un número irracional,
por lo tanto, estoy diciendo que "x" debería ser...
debería ser...
ser racional...
racional...
y justo aquí es cuando llego a la contradicción,
"x" no puede ser racional e irracional
al mismo tiempo,
esto no tiene sentido o es racional o es irracional,
por lo tanto, aquí está la contradicción.
Yo había supuesto que "x" es irracional
y llego a que debe ser racional
y eso no tiene sentido,
"x" no puede ser irracional y racional
y entonces llegue a esta contradicción
porque empezamos suponiendo
que racional por irracional es un número racional
y llegamos a que esto no puede ser cierto,
por lo tanto, justo en este momento
estoy probando lo que quería probar acá arriba,
que un racional por un irracional me debe de dar forzosamente un número irracional y está de lujo.
Ya llegué justo a lo que quería.
Para que no lleguemos a una contradicción,
forzosamente un racional por un irracional
me debe de dar un irracional.